thank you very much um so uh thank you
all again for your attention in the
first part of the lecture um so i'm
gonna right now i'm going to conclude
the the first phase of my talk which is
just a warm-up of gritty blow and
euclidean space motivating the kinds of
assumptions that we're going to be
looking at on energies and the structure
we're going to be looking for when we go
into the metric space context and one
thing that i didn't have time for in the
first part of today's lecture was to
talk about time discretization of the
gradient flow and this is something i
really wanted to talk about both because
you know there are a lot of people at
this workshop who live in a fully
discrete world and also because this
type of discretization is actually a key
tool in um studying partial differential
equations with a gradient flow structure
okay so the time what do i mean by time
discretization so um
i didn't have time uh in in the earlier
part of my lecture to talk about you
know more general notions of continuity
lower semi-continuity it turns out that
even if your energy isn't continuously
differentiable you can get by um with
the existence and uniqueness theory of a
gradient flow if it's merely lower
semi-continuous and anyone's interested
i can say a little bit more about that
at the end
um and then lambda conducts i talked
about that assumption that was the key
assumption that we needed for uh a
uniqueness um so under these two
assumptions uh
the gradient flow um is is well defined
you know maybe you need a generalized
notion of gradient or maybe this is just
the classical addition of gradient in
euclidean space uh and if you want to
discretize this ode in time um a natural
way is to consider an implicit boiler
scheme and so for an implicit eulerstein
basically what you do is you say oh the
time derivative that's you know a
derivative it's basically just change in
y over change in x so in the top we have
uh the change um
in
x and the bottom we have the change in t
so we're thinking of t or within your
tau is the size of our time step so this
is a
a discrimination of the time derivative
and then on the right hand side instead
of having x of t we have x of n x of n
okay so we're replacing our continuous
time solution by a discrete time
sequence this is an implicit method
because x event appears on both sides of
the equation we can't solve explicitly
uh for the for x of n in terms of the
previous step x n minus 1. and of course
we initialize the sequence with the same
initial data that we chose for the
continuous equation
okay so given that this is an implicit
sequence or an implicit scheme
given the n minus 1 element of the
scheme how do you find the nth element
of the scheme so that this equation is
satisfied uh you know this is uh
something you know people in
optimization uh know very well um it
turns out that under the assumptions
that we have on the energy a natural
thing to do is just to look for the
minimizer
of this
new function
so what i'm going to do is i'm going to
take
uh this is a function of x and i'm going
to take the square
square distance i guess i'm still here
um in euclidean space uh my notes jumped
ahead to the metric space case so you
know you can basically see the same
thing in the metric space case
uh so here we're still including a case
so i'm just going to write absolute
value
of the norm squared
and uh
and then plus
okay so
uh
why does this
now we've converted um this equation
into an optimization problem why does
this optimization problem make sense
well we're still in euclidean space we
know that the squared distance
uh you can
bound the testing from below by a
constant two in other words it's two
convex for the positive and then we
multiply it by one over two tau so this
whole thing here is just going to be one
over tau convex
and then we're assuming that the energy
is lambda convex
and so
the sum of these two things is going to
be one over tau plus lambda x
uh
and that's great because while lambda is
a fixed number and could be negative
as long as i take my time step
sufficiently small this is going to be
strictly positive so this will be a
strongly convex function i already know
my energy is lower semi-continuous of
course my distance is continuous and so
i know that there exists a unique
minimizer to this problem um so there
exists a unique minimizer of this
optimization problem and then if you
think okay well great you can solve this
optimization problem how does this help
you up there um well
by looking at the uh you know we know
that there's kind of a sufficiently nice
function and there exists a unique
minimizer we know that the derivative of
that function um must vanish at the
minimizer so if we take the derivative
of this or the gradient of this um and
evaluated at the minimizer we know that
that should be zero but taking the
gradient of this and setting it equal to
zero is exactly saying that that
equation holds up there okay so um so
this is a way of kind of solving this
implicit method by converting it into an
optimization problem
and this is a
very famous
uh
problem in optimizations is often
referred to as the proximal map
um so this time discretization is
somehow very fundamental to the gradient
flow and even at the discrete time level
we preserve two of the key properties of
the continuous time gradient fluid
um the first is that we still preserve a
type of energy dissipation this is kind
of a naive observation
it really follows directly from the
definition of the discrete time scheme
but it turns out that along the discrete
time scheme
the energy is dissipated in this way
uh and you can see this
just by saying
using the fact that
x if x of x sub n is the optimizer of
this problem
of this functional then the value of
this functional x of n is smaller than
the value of this at x of n minus one
then if you rearrange you get exactly
this energy dissipation so
great the energy is decreasing along the
the this sort of time discretized
version of the problem just like it
discretizes it decreases in time a lot
of the continuous time problem and we
even have sort of an estimate
um and then the other key property of
the continuous time problem that's still
preserved at the discrete level um is
the fact that things contract um
you can prove and i i considered proving
it that i'm already right a little low
on time that we can happy to go through
it later it's just a few lines
that
the disagree time problem
contracts at the following rate
uh and
this rate may look a little bit
different from what were talking about
at the continuum time level where we had
for example
e to the negative lambda t
but if you
take what's here in the parentheses and
you take the scaling that my time step
equals
t over n
and you send into infinity
you can see that this exactly converges
to e to the negative lambda
at time t so you really do recover um
the continuous time contraction
okay so
these two properties mean that a lot of
the time pve people we prefer to work at
this discrete time level um and so i i
think um
in that sense uh we're kind of kindred
spirits um with the optimization crowd
um working at the discrete time level
can simplify a lot of things and and
then passing to the continuous time
limit once you have all these nice
estimates is uh not so much of a problem
can you tell us what you gained by this
or yes exactly so if you do explicit
euler lambda convexity is not enough
then you also need uh you need
smoothness controls over the gradient so
you need like a two-sided lipschitz
condition so i can get by with uh with
so
and i can get by with
less information on my energy here um
and
like i said there's lots of energies i
care about like the entropy
uh where i'm not going to be able to get
a two-sided lipsticks estimate i have to
make make do with something like this um
so uh so yeah it's it's motivated by the
specific applications um
uh that i have in my types of
uh ill-behaved energies that i want to
apply this to
and also i guess i i feel like the
implicit method is so close
it's so close to the continuous time
like the properties are exactly the same
as it's at the continuous time so um
somehow it feels like and the the
criteria for existence and uniqueness is
linked exactly with what we need at the
continuous time as well
okay so um
uh i think i'm going i was gonna you
know
step back and give a little bit of a
historical perspective on on radiant
flow techniques and pde and why gradient
flow really has a long theory
long history in pde um for example
yesterday we learned about the heat
equation it's a gradient flow and a
hillbrook space and l2 space of the deer
schleich energy um and then on the other
hand there's been a lot of reasons of
interest in boston gradient flows and
pds of this type of a fossil shine
gradient flow structure of that energy
um i think i'm not going to go into too
much detail here except for to say that
um
hilbert's faces are really nice if you
want to do a gradient flow on a
hilbert's face things work really well
you want to do l2 if you want to do h
minus one you know pick the hilbert
space and and and things will be
beautiful because you have this you know
nice inner product structure there's a
natural way to define the gradient um
but sometimes you can't sometimes the
hilbert space doesn't give you what you
want um and there's two reasons that uh
hilbert's night might not give you what
you want um the gradient flow structure
is really rigid if you have some
specific dynamics in mind like that's
what we do coming from the pd side we
have some dynamics in mind we have for
example a model of biological chemotaxis
in mind that we want to study and we
have to sort of guess the energy and
guess the metric that will give us the
the gradient flow that matches the
dynamics we want so sometimes the
dynamics you have you just can't get
them you can't guess an energy that will
give you a gradient flow structure um
you know like for example um
oh yeah we'll just say leave it at that
so sometimes that's a problem and then
other times maybe you don't have the
dynamics in mind so much maybe you
really have the energy in mind and then
you're trying to pick a metric and then
it's beneficial to try to pick a metric
that will give you good convexity
properties um so the you know given a
fixed energy um it could have much
better conductivity properties with
respect to one metric or another you
know like a very simple example is if i
just picked my energy to be a fixed
external potential
if i look at the conduction where v is a
strongly convex function maybe lambda
conducts from land to positive if i look
at the conductivity properties of this
with respect to l2
this energy is just going to be zero
index but if i look at in the
voser-style metric suddenly it strongly
conducts its landing conducts um so
that's another
consideration that can guide your choice
is that the underlying geometry can
sometimes give you better convexity
properties
okay and i can talk about um the
connections between gradient flow and pd
a little more um at the end basically
it's this uh really rigid framework that
allows us to vary a lot of other things
with the pde and um you know can
sometimes uh shed light on the analysis
okay so um
one of the main goals of my talk was to
tell you about how this gradient flow
theory in euclidean space can be
naturally generalized on metric spaces
so let's consider
a complete metric space x and d
and we want to figure out what is the
analog of this gradient for equation
that we saw in finite dimensions
so as i've already argued
this ordinary differential equation
turns out to be equivalent to this
inequality here so can we somehow use
this inequality to define a gradient
flow on an arbitrary vector space
okay so in order to do that i'm going to
need to somehow say what is this on a
metric space and what is this automatic
space
so first i'm going to talk about the
time derivative and this is called the
metric derivative
so i have some curve in my metric space
so x takes in times and the interval
zero to t and spits out points in my
metric space so that's some curve
uh and i have uh
i can define its metric derivative
um by just evaluating this limit
so
this is just saying that the distance
between the curve at time s and the
curve at time t divided by s minus t
take the limit as s goes to t now it's
totally possible this you know in
general this limit won't exist like you
have like weird curves that jump around
in your metric space um but if this does
exist it tells us a little bit about the
um smoothness and time of our curve
and so this is going to play the role
of this absolute value of the time
derivative here and sure enough you can
check that if you replace the metric
here with just the euclidean norm this
reduces to the absolute value of the
time derivative
and the second quantity i need to tell
you about is how we're going to
generalize this
the great the
absolute value of the gradient of e
so for this i'm going to assume that i
have an energy defined on my metric
space
um another thing that i i sort of rushed
through at the beginning is at the
beginning i was only allowing energies
that were real valued it turns out in
general you can extend this to energies
that you know maybe attain the value
plus infinity uh the reason you might
want to do that is because that's how
you can encode a constraint set if
you're doing a gradient flow and your
energy is equal to plus infinity on
subset um you're never going to flow
into that set when you're you're doing
gradient of uh evolving in the direction
steepest descent of the energy you might
worry that this constraint set would
then make it you know setting it equal
to plus infinity how do you define the
gradient there are generalizations of
the gradient the sub-differential um
that that make that possible
okay so in this case if we wanted to
find the
the appropriate notion of absolute value
of the gradient
that's called the metric slope and this
is just going to be the limb soup
as y goes to x
of e of x
minus e of y
now i'm going to take the positive part
and i'm going to divide by the distance
between x and y
okay what is the positive part again
this is just the function if i apply the
positive part to a number x
that just says give me what is whatever
is bigger 0
or s so okay so if s is another negative
number it gives you zero if s is
positive it gives yes
all right so why is this the appropriate
generalization of the absolute value of
the gradient um so first thing i think
we need to talk about is what the heck
is going on with this positive part why
do i have a positive part there um the
point is is that i'm doing gradient flow
i'm moving i'm going in in the direction
of steepest descent of the energy and so
when you're doing a gradient flow of the
energy
let's say i'm at some point x and i i
know the value of my energy at this
point and i want to do gradient flow
i don't care about the va about what the
energy is doing at places where it has
higher values i'm never going to move in
that direction
if it's higher values everywhere then
i'm just going to stay where i am that
means i'm already kind of at a local
minimum
um so really if i'm at a point x i only
am looking for where the energy could be
smaller nearby and if there is a place
then i kind of want to move the plate
move in the direction that makes me
smaller more quickly
okay so that's why i have this positive
part here because if i'm at a location x
i'm looking around and i'm trying to
look for where e of y is smaller than e
of x or
in other words where e of x minus e and
y is positive
and then i divide by the distance
between x and y
and so uh
again if you take this and you replace
the the metric with just the standard
euclidean norm you'll see that this
reduces to the absolute value of the
negative part of the gradient
where the gradient jumps down
okay um
okay so and and luckily this always
exists uh we don't have to worry about
questions of existence there because we
have yeah
um okay so now we have a general we have
a
an analog of this we have an analog of
this so we can define um an analog of
this full equation um the only thing
that could be a little funny is the time
derivative on the left-hand side you
know does this time derivative always
exist so what i'm going to do
to side step around that is i'm actually
going to integrate this equation in time
so when i integrate this from t to s
that's just going to turn into a
difference and then i'll have some time
integrals over here
okay so when i do that i arrive at the
definition of something that's called a
curve of maximal slope so i'll say x
this is a blank i'll fill in in a moment
is the curve of maximal slope of an
energy
with initial data
x naught
if at time zero my curve
starts at x naught
and the following inequality holds
uh the value of the energy
at time x of t
minus the value of the energy
uh at time s
has to be less than or equal to so you
can see this is the time integral of
that and so i now want to say less than
or equal to the metric analog of the
time integral of that
and this has to hold uh
for all
s
uh
smaller than little t
on some interval from zero to t
okay so does this make sense
well we can see sort of roughly by
looking at it that this
uh is kind of the time integrated
version of what we had at the top um but
the one thing that we need to specify is
we're not always sure that this limit
exists you know your your curve could be
jumping around in some weird way so so
that it doesn't um so we need to add a
little bit of an extra hypothesis here
to ensure that this limit exists
and that hypothesis is we're going to
assume that x is something called a two
absolutely continuous curve
so it takes in values in this time
interval it spits out locations in my
metric space and we're going to say that
it's too absolutely continuous
in case
uh
the metric slope is squared interval
okay so this imposes a kind of you know
weak notion of regularity and time
in particular this ensures that it's
continuous um in in the metric space but
it's a little bit stronger than this um
and here i mean that this not only does
this exist almost everywhere but um
when i take its integral at this the
integral of its square it's finite
okay so once i add in that extra
assumption
now things
are all good because i know that taking
the integral of the square of that is
allowed this isn't something that um
that exists it's never going to be plus
infinity so i'm never going to end up in
a situation where this is less than or
equal to minus infinity that would be
complicated um okay so this is a
reasonable definition um
something uh that i think can be an
obstruction to learning about gradient
flow and metric spaces and in the
vascular style metric is there's
actually a bunch of equivalent
definitions or a bunch of definitions of
gradient flow that are equivalent under
some assumptions um so i actually could
have picked a variety of different
definitions to talk about here so let me
just say a few words about why i picked
this definition the thing that i like
about this definition is first you can
read off right from the definition that
the energy is decreasing on along the
flow um since this is such a fundamental
part of gradient flow uh i like that
it's sort of immediately apparent from
from the definition because
uh t is greater than or equal to s
and the right hand side is negative we
automatically get that e of x of t is
less than or equal to e that's s it's
giving us this energy dissipations baked
into the definition
the other thing i like about this
definition is that this definition
doesn't immediately appeal to specific
conductivity properties of the energy um
now don't get me wrong like i love i
love lambda convex energies but as i've
already mentioned there are some
generalizations maybe like an omega
convex energy and i like a definition
that doesn't um that kind of is robust
enough that it works for energies with
different types of convexity properties
um you know whatever whatever
assumptions you need to impose to ensure
uniqueness you can it's not something
that's baked into the definition
what would be a definition that uses
second order information to define it
the evolution variational equality that
jan was talking about yesterday so there
if you only said it in the complex case
um but you can do a lambda and backstage
and one of that
and then the grand version
so actually talking about yeah i mean i
remember when i you know first thought
about all this and you know the work
metric is uh being thrown around a
little bit and you know when you
graduate in metric spaces but if you
come from a computer science background
when you think about a metrics you're
thinking about a discrete space with
like you know graph metric maybe a
dialogue
and
this completely collapses right i mean
there's this this in a way requires to
have like you know continuous curves
between points like we're talking about
spaces and i think maybe this is what
sinha was hinting at when he asked about
you know it almost has a romanian
structure like all this curves being ac2
sort of gives you some sort of a you
know error set for a differential
structure on the space right
like
is any of this working in a discrete
setting
well i mean as as young you know pointed
out last night we can we can come up
with examples of metric spaces in which
no
no you know um continuous curves exist
um and so uh you know okay then then
then you would have to kind of maybe
think of a different definition i guess
if you if i were to try to do something
on a discrete space with a metric where
no continuous curves um exist
then i i would probably try to think of
it as a discretization of a different
problem and then and then to find the
gradient flow at the continuum level um
so yeah i guess to me gradient flow is
inherently a continuous continuous time
thing um and so i don't feel like it's
it's
uh when defining it on a metric space it
seems natural to me that continuous
curves must exist in order for it to be
well defined um but but yeah it would be
interesting um so and and maybe i'll
come to this in a moment um a key
assumption for for uh that i'm going to
talk about today for us to get existence
and uniqueness in this is a connects the
assumption on the metric space and then
to test convex you have to text there
you have to test it along geodesics
there have to exist
um between points um so yeah there
definitely is some some continuity baked
into this but i'm still
now yeah you know now i need to come up
with a question or an example of a
metric that you agree is very far from
romanian but where we can have a curve
of maximal slope exist because i i i
think maybe we can come up with an
example of that
okay um
okay so uh all right so great we have a
an analog of um gradient of a definition
of gradient flow in a metric space um
but a lot of questions remain just like
in the in the euclidean space you know
when when do these exist um
we want to so an audience please see if
you can come up with an example of
existence on a really weird metric space
by the end of this talk um when do they
when are they unique what are their key
properties um and to what extent does
this coincide uh you know this
definition which seems very far from the
pdes i was mentioning at the beginning
why does this definition coincide with
the pdes that i was mentioning at the
beginning in the case that the
underlying metric is the possible strain
metric
okay so um
just like in the euclidean space
convexity or you know generalized
notions of condensation such as laminar
convexity or omega convexity is going to
play a key role and in euclidean space
we tested convexity along lines between
points and now we're going to test them
along geodesics in our metric space so
we need to define what is a geodesic um
and so i'll say that a curve that you
know takes in times and spits out
locations in my metric space
is a geodesic
um if if
if the following holds
the distance between
my curve at time alpha and my curve at
time beta
is equal to
is
equal to
the um difference between alpha and beta
times
uh the distance between the curve at
time one and time
zero okay so basically uh one way to
interpret this is that the curve is
moving sort of at constant speed uh with
respect to the metric structure and for
that reason this is often even called a
constant speed of geodesic to kind of
emphasize that property of it okay so
the belief's right sometimes these
things don't exist um so
uh but this is the definition
um and then how i'm going to
to define convexity in a metric space
context is i'm going to say that some
energy i have is lambda conducts um if
for any points um in my metric space
there exists a geodesic okay so now i'm
assuming that that geodesics exist
between points from x naught to x one um
so that the following inequality folds
um it's exactly the the generalization
of what you would expect from the
euclidean space
so the value of the energy along the
curve at time alpha is less than or
equal to one minus alpha the value of
the energy along the curve at time zero
plus alpha times the energy along the
curve at time one if i didn't write
anything else this would just be
convexity but because i say lambda
convexity i allow it to have kind of a
quadratic term
depending on lambda
uh and i won't go into details but you
can write this for omega convexity as
well
okay so um
all right so we have a notion of
convexity um in metric spaces uh
is this everything we need to get these
things um
well it turns out that
when you actually want to prove that a
curve of maximal slope exists um you
actually go back to that same time
discrimination we were talking about in
euclidean space um that's how you
construct the the curve of maximal slope
by solving the sequence minimization
problems um so
this time discretization works great uh
even at a metric space uh we define it
exactly the same way
given the n minus one step of this
discrete time scheme we can define the
if step
uh to be the minimum
of the analogous quantity except for now
instead of the uh
euclidean norm i have just the metric
square
plus the energy
metric space context this is often
referred to as a minimizing movement
scheme dating back to the work of
georgie or um jordan kinderlairer and
otto um popularize this scheme in the in
the case of a embosser side metric when
for the [ __ ] or plunk equation um in
fact it has become so popular i think it
is somehow the most cited siam article
of all time or something like this uh
that for this reason people have now
stopped calling this minimizing
movements and often even call this jko
even when the distance isn't the boss or
stymetric um but yeah maybe minimizing
movements is a slightly better name for
general uh general distances
um
okay so
uh
so we knew that this made lots of sense
at the euclidean stand level uh do we
always have a minimizer of this problem
um in the metric space case uh you know
is this problem well defined um so one
easy sufficient condition under which
it's definitely well defined is that if
the square distance is convex
uh excuse me if it's i so i put one half
the square distance and i want it to be
one convex or you know the square
distance itself is too much x
so if this is uh one convex um and that
holds you know for whatever
uh reference point x on i'm evaluating
that
uh then
as long as my energy is lambda convex
that's sufficient uh further uh in the
lower continuous for there to exist a
unique minimizer of this optimization
problem
um can you just point out that this this
method is the proximal appointment
that's exactly what it was yes
yes and i yes so where are people
inventing new names for it
uh that's a fair question
but yeah i know i thought this is often
referred to as the proximal map um
you know even even in the 60s i think
moreover was using this sort of
dimensionals but yeah so um
so yeah that's a great question why why
not just call it the proximal point
method
um
so uh okay so as long as so of course in
euclidean space this is convex and so
then you have the whole thing would be
one over tail convex this is lambda
convex you add them together pick tau
small enough and it's a strongly convex
optimization problem um so that's great
if your square distance is one convex
and we have a special name for metric
spaces like that those are metric spaces
with non-positive curvature
and uh we know that this is an important
uh property in optimization and the
optimization lectures we heard on the
first day they often restrict um to
consider romanian manifolds which have
non-positive curvature um because you
know in that case this proximal point
method behaves really well
unfortunately the bosser's diametric is
not this type of metric space in fact it
has positive curvature
so things start to break down for us
right away
so we need to figure out what to do with
this proximal point method or minimizing
the hit scheme
when the square distance
is not convex
sorry yes you need the convexity of the
the metric or the square of the magic
only for for uniqueness right so
in general case lower continuity would
actually be enough to define this
yes indeed and um i think i the reason
why i am talking about it so
i have to introduce
i've already introduced lambda convexity
to get uniqueness of the continuum time
gradient flow indeed i don't need lambda
convexity here there will exist some
minimum um but the the metric space
theory is best developed in the case of
lambda convexity along generalized
geodesics and i think the best way to
motivate the need for generalized
geodesics is at the level of this
optimization problem
but you're right that uh this is a
little bit more of a pedagogical uh
approach as opposed to necessary
conditions
okay so uh what about if the square
distance is non-convex as it is in the
in the master same case
um so then we need a slightly stronger
connectivity assumption um so this is
maybe most precisely defined only in the
voltage time metric but i'm going to
sort of feel the definition there and
pose it on an arbitrary metric space
so i will say that an energy you know on
my metric space
is lambda convex a long generalized
geodesic so this is a going to be a
stronger convexity assumption than what
i mentioned before which is just lambda
convex along geodesics this is going to
require that convexity inequality to
hold along more curves not just
adjectives
um
uh and this is going to be true if for
um any points in my metric space we'll
say we have an x naught an x one and an
x tilde
there exists a curve
between them
so a curve x t
connecting x not x one
such that
uh
this
function here which i'll define as phi
sub
x n minus 1 of x function of x
okay rather than i'm going to say we
could consider its value to general x
tilde
such that this uh is one over tau
uh plus lambda x
okay so this is a weird definition
um what i'm saying here is
that if i just consider geodesics
between points x naught and x1
i don't necessarily know if this
function is going to be convex a long
data6
but it turns out that in some metric
spaces like the positive sign metric you
can find these other curves
that it is convex along those other
curves and you can show those other
curves exist and connect any two points
um so it somehow
conducts the assumption on a richer
class of curves
yes
so 25 is for every towel
uh let's say for tau sufficiently small
so i will say um
quartal
uh
i'll require this to be positive for
example one over tau so if if lambda is
um
positive
uh then it could be for all tau uh if
lambda's negative it's fertile
sufficiently small
um
so
i'm going to abbreviate this assumption
as a
lambda convex on generalized guesses
okay so once we have so once we have
this assumption this is exactly what we
need to get uniqueness of solutions to
this minimization problem as leon
pointed out existence of solutions isn't
a problem but you might worry that there
are two but if there are two solutions
all you need to do is connect them with
one of these general curves because your
energy is going to be strictly convex
along it um it shows that those two
points actually had to be the same they
were both going to be minimizers of this
energy so that's what gives you
uniqueness
and this assumption also turns out to
just be uh important for developing the
theory of curves of maximal soap on a
metric space um in in the nicest way um
which is the setting i i wanted to uh
give for this kind of introductory work
um and so and
in particular in ambrosia's julian
savarese um 2005 book
they show that if our energy is lower
semi-continuous okay proper
can't equal plus infinity everywhere um
and lambda convects along these
generalized geodesics then for any
initial condition in d of e so this is
just a little uh
notation uh i take d d of e this is just
the domain of the energy because since
now i'm allowing my um
my energy to equal plus infinity you
know
these are just the points for the
energy's
not plus i'm going to be
um
so for any um initial condition as long
as the energy is not plus infinity there
uh then it turns out that there exists a
unique
curve of maximal slope
um
furthermore
uh the energy dissipation equality holds
in particular what that means is that if
you come back up to this definition of
curve of maximal soap actually equality
holds there
um
and uh
you know kind of part of that energy
dissipation by because that energy
dissipation inequality holds then we
actually know that our evaluating our
energy along the flow is sufficiently
regular that we can differentiate it
um we get a contraction
just like we had uh
in the euclidean case
uh
you can also do this for omega convex
not semiconductors
uh and then you can also get rates of
convergence on the time discrimination
you can prove that the time
discretization
converges at an ordered tail
and that is the time step
all right so um so
now we we've seen how to take the these
key ideas from including a space
gradient form to adapt them um in
geometric space uh
constant context um uh and and get a lot
of the same nice results that we had in
the euclidean space so uh what remains
uh to be seen is how this metric space
perspective um connects it all to those
pdes that i mentioned at the beginning
of the talk um this definition of a
curve of maximal slope somehow seems
seems kind of far away uh from those
equations so
now i'm going to zoom in on the vasa
sign gradient flow context and tell you
what are the special things about the
vessels metric that allow us to take
something that's just a curve of maximal
slope just satisfies this sort of
inequality and characterize it as a pde
sorry i have a question
in
in the hilbert's phase context bracey's
theory shows us that you can also extend
the gradient flow to data which has
infinite uh infinite energy with some
smoke and so this can happen here too i
could have put closure of the junction
so you can get some density of the
domain in the whole metric space for
some you can do it on the closure of the
domain yeah okay yeah but i guess only
for lumbar convex functions
okay so now we're going to zoom in on
this bosserstein case so we're
considering
um the space of probability measures
with finite second moment as i was
introduced yesterday endowed
with the two bosses time metric
um so how does a curve of maximal slope
relate to pde in this case
and so i'm going to talk about three key
properties of phosphorous diametric um
which were kind of
proved in the way that i'm going to
state them by ambrose usually in
sabareto they really date back to
earlier words especially by ben and
didn't they
so the first
very special thing about the bosserstein
case is that it turns out
then if you have a curve in that metric
space which is too absolutely continuous
so you know at first glance this is just
something that takes in times and spits
out things in our metric space spits out
probability measures
um
but in fact because of this regularity
in time
you can show that there exists a
velocity field
you don't know what it is but it exists
such
that
rho is a solution of the continuity
equation
and furthermore
that the l2 norm of that velocity field
with respect to rho
is exactly
this metric derivative
okay so
this is where pdes come into play it's
that somehow just by being sufficiently
regular in this vosserstein metric
you get for free a characterization in
terms of pde in here i mean you know a
weak solution and duality bound to
continuous functions
yeah exactly so so what how is that
yeah
a weak solution and the do our sorry
let's say the duality would continuously
compactly supported functions
so these are functions from rd types are
so is the vice versa so suppose i have
a flaw and it's a weak solution
can i as long as this holds
and it is this is square integrable so
you need that and then it's actually
very nice characterization
um
uh and so you know from a a
kind of moral perspective this really is
dating back um to the work of been a
moon bernier uh
this is in some ways it's just a
different way
um so this is something that's really
nice about about the baltic site setting
is you get this sort of beautiful pde
characterization that curves with
sufficient time regularity and you're
able to link that pde characterization
to the metric derivative
is there a short formal moral proof for
this interesting statement
oh
i i don't i'm not i'm probably is but i
i don't have one off the top of my head
um
okay well you can see that uh the
solutions are pushed forward so the
characteristics typically for the
continued iteration
that's what uh at the end so but the but
why would having this regularity in the
vosser science since
so if it's that if it's a curve then you
say define the
uh okay so let's say it's all densities
so you can define
an optimal transport map that pushes the
initial condition to the something at
time t
uh
uh
and then you can say and those density
solves an ordinary differential equation
because those densities are sufficiently
regular in time and so i guess then
there has to exist a velocity field
driving those densities and then you
could do it yeah so i don't know yeah
depends on if that is what you had in
mind for a simple proof
i'm not sure if it was
just
so um
okay uh so all right so this is the
first special property of the of the
shine case um so now i'm this is a
special property of the voltage
diametric and now i'm going to start
linking together
uh where the volkswagen style metric
works with these energies which have
these kind of key assumptions of lower
symmetry continuity and lambda convexity
along generalized to geodesics
so the next key property is that
for
uh
for any element of the sub differential
this is something that i've uh
shamefully not defined at all i intended
to invite an rd case that i didn't have
time but let us just say it's kind of a
generalized notion of gradient what
makes sense for lowers to mean
continuous functions it really comes
straight from that above the tangent
line inequality that i mentioned for
lambda index functions so you can think
of this as sort of a type of gradient
we have a chain rule
so this is something it is gonna look
familiar
so
you can differentiate the energy along a
two absolutely continuous curve and what
you get is
sort of the thing that plays the role of
your gradient
and whereas normally here i would kind
of write the direction of that the curve
is evolving in like rho dot of t
now i'm going to write the velocity
field that's driving that evolution
okay so
uh
what's underlying this is the sort of
pseudo-ramanian structure of the
monster's temperature
is what gives us this
chain rule
okay
um so this is something that's very
special about the fossils diametric um
and then the last thing that i will say
um works for energies whenever they're
sort of first variation is well defined
and
that means if you consider perturbations
of the energy
kind of along lines
so you know
considering the value of the energy rho
plus
say t mu minus
uh
e of rho
divided by t
um if i can write this
the limit as t goes to zero of this as
the integral
of this quantity
um against
okay so if you're sometimes you're
introduced sufficiently nice but this is
no problem in fact for all of the
energies i mentioned this is no problem
um but you can under counter some weird
energies for
their problems i'm sorry for the sub
differential does that mean you compose
v with rho and then compute the sub
differential of a real function or is it
this is the sub
this is something that is defined and
ambrosia billions
and basically it's just done you know
using that above the tangent line um
functional and
if you you use the sort of formal inner
product uh uh uh for the vastus diameter
to stand in for the inner product that
you saw on youtube in space
so yes i'm i'm hiding
a lot here but i guess my goal was just
to extract what are these special things
from boston spine that make
connect curves of maximal slope to these
nice pdes and the reason i wanted to
extract them is because it turns out
that people are cooking up a lot of
interesting metrics
based kind of taking boss or sinusoidal
inspiration that preserve a lot of these
properties and then they can still study
a lot of interesting pdus so that's why
i wanted to to kind of call these things
out it may not be so easy to find these
things in the wild for an arbitrary
metric that you pick up but maybe you
can uh modify the voxer style metric
and
that preserves these in some way and you
can still get some interesting gradient
flows to study dynamics that you're
interested in okay so in this last case
when we do have a
first variation um then it turns out
that the first variation is closely
related um to the subdifferential
in fact
the the gradient of the first variation
is an element of the subdifferential
uh
and we get a nice characterization of
this
metric slope that we defined the metric
slope is the l2 norm
of the gradient of this first variation
okay so uh you know it's pretty pretty
special property of w2 that we get this
sort of nice expression um for both the
sub-differential and for the metric
slope
in terms of you know i'm not sure how
familiar this is but but to as kind of a
pda person doing gradient flow in
hilbert's cases this is a very familiar
quantity
okay so
these three key
properties of vosser's time metric allow
us to connect the curve of maximal slope
to the pde they give us the following
theorem
uh if we have a curve of maximal slope
uh rho x t so this is just you know a
curve in the space of probability
measures that satisfy that inequality
then it turns out
that
it satisfies this continuity equation
okay so i am going to give a short proof
of this using these three facts um that
i've told you these special properties
of the vosserstein metric that uh
the reason i can do a short proof is
because there's not too much leave now
i've hidden all the deep things in these
other properties okay so how are we
going to prove this um well because
by the first point i made
um if row is a curve of maximal slope in
particular that ensures that it is a two
absolutely continuous curve so by the
first point i know that there exists
a velocity field v
uh such that
um my
uh curve
is a solution of the continuity equation
with v
the velocity field v
um so thus it suffices to show
that this v
is equal to negative that
okay
um okay so that's that's what i want to
do and i somehow need to do this using
the definition of a curve of maximal
slope um so uh
like i already said for for kind of
sufficiently nice energies energies that
are lower semi-continuous and then it
can maximum generalized geodesics um
it's no problem uh to actually uh to
differentiate the energy um and we had
this chain rule up here so i'll just
copy that and bring it down
okay and then now i'm just going to use
that same inequality i've been uh using
all day which is the
a times b is greater than or equal to
negative a squared over two minus b
squared over two with equality only if a
equals negative b
and i'm going to say that this here
is greater than or equal to
uh negative one-half
uh
oh um
one other observation is i need to use
part three that this is an element of
the sub differential so
the
c i choose here
can be
okay so now i'm going to use this
inequality
to say that this is greater than or
equal to
the first variation
of e
taking its gradient with respect to l2
minus
the l2 norm of the velocity
okay and then i've already identified
what these things are so
[Music]
thank you
i've already identified uh
what these things are um so this here
was exactly the square of the um
of the metric slope
and this here we already said the l2
norm of the velocity this is exactly the
metric derivative
um
and then uh
finally by what is the definition of
oops we said what is the definition of a
curve of maximal slope um well if we go
back to the definition
we can see
a curve of maximal slope is if this
inequality held now i already know that
because my energy is sufficiently nice i
can actually take the limit as time goes
t goes to s dividing both sides and now
this just becomes an upper bound on e x
of t in terms of
uh
uh
this quantity evaluated at x of t and
this quantity
at r of t and this is evaluated at r of
t so curve of maximal slope tells me um
that i uh i get um that this here is an
upper bound for the time derivative of
my energy
and that's exactly what i need right
here so this is the thing that you would
have on the right hand side of a
curve of maximal slope
and i know that that's an upper bound
for the time derivative of my energy
okay so
in other words i know that
actually equalities must hold throughout
and because here i use that this this
inequality where equality only holds an
a equals negative b i'm able to conclude
that v actually equals negative the
gradient of the first variation of e
with respect to rho
so that was what i needed to show
okay um so and okay this is true uh well
almost everywhere but that's fine for
our
transformation
okay so i think i will um stop there uh
if i also have a few remarks on kind of
convexity things and the vaso sign said
so i'd be very happy if anyone wants to
discuss those uh details later clearly
um a key assumption and everything i'm
doing is that you need some sort of
convectivity properties on the energy um
sometimes it needs to be this lambda
convexity along generalized geodesics
sometimes just landed regular lambda
convexity is enough sometimes even sort
of a generalized convection like omega
city is enough so happy to talk about
that more often are interested
uh
so my question is about
the other connections
so if you have
a weak solution of this
well i i you need you still need this
sort of like that the
um
i guess you would need that it's a weak
solution of this pde and you need some
square integrability of the velocity
field with respect to the problem
so in time
yes does this imply that
solutions
uh
so i guess of course you would need to
like yeah so somebody gives me a
solution of the forest medium equation
um okay i would i would first need to
yeah i would i'd say what kind of
solution um do you have in mind so i
would need to prove that their notion of
solution implied that it was a weak
solution of the porous medium equation
their notion of solution would also come
with some regularity and time
that regularity and time would probably
uh
you know be enough in order for me to
get like whatever bound i wanted on the
uh
the the time regularity
uh
of this pde in particular it would
improve this poop and apply this time
regularity in the ac2 sense
so
i think what's he meant to say that you
look at the location
and
on top of that we are going to assume
some integrability conditions what are
here inside the divergence you are going
to understand some integrality
conditions
and that is enough to tell you that
you are
on the versus time space
so
so there are some
so but i need to know that there exists
a solution that is
just uh wanted to ask is there a way to
uh have grading forward like a curve of
maximal slope like well defined when uh
when your metric space is positive curve
and
the uh functional of interest is like
not
uh cgg yes uh i just picked this
assumption because this is where the
theory is most beautiful and well
developed so i thought it was most
appropriate for an introductory lecture
um indeed you don't need lambda cgg to
get existence of a gradient flow in that
case you do need some coercivity as you
know professional scenarios already
pointing out so that can play the role
um so yeah as long as you have lower
semi-continuity and some coercivity um
it's fine
uh for existence
and you can even get uniqueness even
with just regular lambda convexity
properties not lambda xbcdg you just
have to know a bit more about the energy
to some things by hand this is just the
case in which the
theory fits together nicely
and interestingly in the voserstein case
while lambda cgg
is a stronger assumption than the usual
lambda convexity logistics we don't have
any examples of energies
for which we can see a strict like all
of the energies we care about in
practice if they are lambda conducts
along geodesics they are also lambda cgg
so sort of effectively in practices it
is not a much stronger assumption
so so this may be a nice question but uh
so when you went from the euclidean
space to
general matrix spaces
you took a particular characterization
and then uh that is the way you
presented it you just took the right
things
which you thought would be generally
can you talk a little bit about like
why some other approach of whether
people are practicing or i mean why this
is natural and how how people desire
um i'd say my best the the
why it seemed natural to me or
um
uh though we have a lot of experts in
the audience who probably know much more
about the history than i do is i would
say it's really natural compared to the
time discretization i think people
really started working at the discrete
time level and and then wanting to pass
to the limit as tau goes to zero and you
can write an exact analog of this curve
of maximal slope definition um which i
guess i have up at the top there
you can write an exact uh analog of that
in discrete time along the discrete time
sequence um and so uh it it just it it
follows it's pretty direct i mean it's
not too bad to go just
using this fairly simple definition here
to kind of cook up a discrete time
version of this
and so
i guess i would say maybe that's one of
the reasons this is uh was the way in
which they chose to
extend the theory
[Music]
thank you katie uh this was a great
lecture um and um
i mean
somehow the setting here is always a
metric space but if you
i don't know consider something a little
bit more general for the d to say if d
is a one of those pseudo or quasimetric
or something like that
and specifically the quasimetric say
when you lose a symmetry
i mean is there anything like this like
of this level of generality where people
can talk about curves of maximal
slope and you know connections with the
fincillary geometry et cetera et cetera
or i'm not aware of that but i think
there may be some other people who have
looked at the occasion so unfortunately
we had to deal with this uh in our uh
upper scheme as if you look at the
upward speed then
the symmetry is lost it's uh quasimetric
so the distance is no longer uh
symmetric right and i just have one
remark there to make which was noted by
storm and collaborator right is that in
a plaza metric space convexity is not
the right notion for stability so you
can have convex
complexity and yet not have stability
there is some skew convexity that needs
to be considered for stability so that
was kind of interesting uh that okay
that's one of the things where convinced
is not the right thing to do but kind of
let's say in our setting where there's
still a quadratic structure actually
this uh slope because you only go
forwards you don't care so much about
symmetry the existence actually doesn't
go through so this is so robust that it
even works in quasi-metric spaces so
yeah this is an example of the type of
work where they're
able to generalize this
so
you can consider also a
case of so you start with a
lagrangian and you define a first
function program
without that you can also have the same
and minimizing the same idea of proof to
what to prove an instance and of course
for the lagrangian you don't have a
structure
[Music]